[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
c'est le portrait de la comtesse main
par leoni sa nièce
[Musique]
c'est charmant une finesse une grâce
elle a du talent 7 lundi qu'est ce que
j'entends cha cha au pardon mademoiselle
justement c'est des caissettes poule à
estaires pardonnez moi mademoiselle
léonie deauville gonthier nous regarder
le portrait de madame votre tante notre
maîtresse et carrier reconnu tout de
suite car il y ressemblant qui vous
demande votre avis les lettres les
journaux oui alors je suis allé ce matin
à lyon à la place du coach et qui n'en
avait pas le temps et j'ai rapporté des
lettres pour tout le monde là pour
mademoiselle d'abord et bien donné de
paris d'hortense mon ami d'enfance son
ami d'enfance ce charmant cerveau et
s'inquiète des troubles de lyon des
complots qui nous environne quant à la
cour il est difficile que ce night bien
sous un roi qui fait des vers latins et
qu'il donne jamais palace une lettre
dont la comtesse madame la comtesse
cécile d'autres val n'est de kermadio
est un bris d'auray au aurait plein vent
des abats c'est tout simple une
excellente royalistes comme madame
encore pas alors celle-ci pour le frère
madame la comtesse et pour monsieur
gustov de grignon un jeu de maître des
requêtes est ici depuis dix jours il
suffit des journaux oui les voici dans
un show liétard des villes c'est que le
coach est la femme de chambre voulait
lire avant madame et mademoiselle ce qui
est leur manquer de respect et je me
suis opposé c'est bien j'ai suffisamment
pas tant je ne croyais pas que
mademoiselle me blâme redmond ce qui
souvent dit est le plus c'est l'excès
comme disait monsieur de talent
voilà qui est trop fort monsieur charles
se permettrait de haut
[Applaudissements]
ce qui revient à ma tante ce qui vient
monsieur charges qui cite monsieur de
talent un homme qui a porté malheur à
tous ceux qu'il a servie mauvaise
recommandations pour un domestique
assure-toi charles aurait lu ça quelque
part sans comprendre
n'est ce pas forcément madame je ne
pensais pas que cela offusque à
mademoiselle offusque à un subjonctif à
présent trois mois de plus vous parlez
trop je connais vos bonnes qualités
votre dévouement pour moi mais vous
oubliez trop souvent votre situation
subalterne
oui mais ne pensait pas vous l'a rappelé
notre place d'ailleurs n'est pas ici je
vous ai pris uniquement pour soigner les
jeunes chevaux de mon frère
allez à votre service bien madame merci
madame
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à monsieur charles jusqu'au 2 mai
ce type qui veulent se donner de
l'importance aux mets une importance
vous l'avez pas les attentes en vérité
comme moi dans cela est bien figurer en
hollande en tout à l'heure laisse moi
d'abord parcourir mon courrier
c'est triste je viens dire le mien cden
pour vos amis comme elle tremblait en
écrivant ma chère cécile soyez bénis
mille fois je reprends espoir depuis que
je sais mon fils auprès de vous votre
château situé à deux lieux de la
frontière lui permet d'attendre sans
danger l'issue de ce procès fatale et
d'ailleurs qui pourrait soupçonner que
le château de la comtesse d'autres val
n'est de kermadio recèle un homme accusé
de conspiration contre le roi du reste
que vos opinions politiques se rassurent
est ce que mon coeur a des opinions
politiques
enfin henri monfils n'est pas coupable
un malheureux coup de tête qu'il vous
racontera l'ua seul donner une apparence
de conspirateurs mais cette apparence
suffirait mais soit pour le perdre
s'il était prise qu'est ce que j'y
caisse dont encore une condamnation à
mort sur le conseil de guerre c'est ans
à lyon hier a condamné le principal chef
du complot bas la partie ce monsieur
henri de flavigny un jeune homme de 25
ans qui heureusement s'est évadé avec
l'aide de quelques amis m'a-t-on dit oui
oui je me rappelle c'est cette évasion
qui excite l enthousiasme de monsieur
gustave de grillons notre jeune maître
de requête
il n'avait qu'un regret c'est d'avoir
été chargé d'une pareille expédition ses
goûts ses bras il a de qui tenir
sa mère qui avait comme moi traversé
toutes les guerres de la vendée sa mère
avec un courage de lions c'est pour moi
qu'ils parlent toujours à table
d'actions héroïques et le curieux c'est
que son père était dit-on peureux comme
un lièvre vraiment alors c'est peut-être
pour ça que l'autre jour il est devenu
tout pâle quand la barque a manqué
chaviré
je lui demanderais car nous avons un
bail et un concert pour votre fête et
j'ai déjà pensé à votre coiffure nasa la
superbe que j'ai vu dans la cei et qui
vous ira à merveille au coq est content
quand john concevrait même pour celui de
tatort ne se tout naturel vous c'est moi
tellement que quand on fait votre éloge
ce qui arrive souvent
je suis tentée de remercier aussi jugé
de mâchoire et quand ma mère m'a permis
de venir passer un mois ici auprès du il
me semblait que rien qu'en regardant
j'allais devenir parfaite en or
vous riez est-ce que j'ai mal parlé non
chers picard c'est ton coeur qui parle
si je souris c'est de tes illusions
c'est ta candeur à me dire je vous
admire quand on embrasse et en
m'appelant ma chère fille je suis
presque aussi heureuse que si
j'entendais ma mère apprend gars en
garde il ne faut femme gâtée ainsi
j'aurai trente chats gras de te voir
partir ce sera ma jeunesse qui s'en ira
ne vous êtes très jeune à lui tout seul
maintenant au certainement d'une genèse
de voyons devine à kochi à jean mi koné
pa majorité des trente 30 jours les faux
on ne peut pas être plus modeste
j'achèverai donc toronto roy 33 ou alors
oui ma chère petite rome 3 l'année
prochaine j'en aurais peut-être plus
prendre de mais maintenant voilà manche
et quelle vieille tante tu as la rue
vieille chaque match une forme qu'a vu
c'est de vous ressembler à ce que tu dis
n'a pas le sens commun c'est la somme
que plaisir les bienvenus au mont élèves
car j'ai premier ta main de te faire
travailler
as-tu dessiner ce matin mais j'étais
descendu pour ça dans le salon nab
et devinez que j'ai trouvé tout à
l'heure devant mon chevalet et regardant
votre portrait qui deux ans monsieur
charles
eh bien eh bien figurez vous attendent
qu'ils disaient c'est charmant elle a du
talent cette léonie et cela t'a rendu
furieux
certainement et ce n'est pas tout
m'attendent croiriez-vous qu'il chante a
fait pire si les gays ce garçon ce que
dieu ne lui a pas permis de chanter
comme un toit mais c'est qu'il chante
très bien
voilà ce qui me révolte coûte mois dont
cela irait je prenais dans le par en
arrivant derrière la halle du bois les
chevreuils
j'entends une voix qui chantaient les
premières mesures d'années de cimarosa
mais une voix charmante une méthode
pleines de goût je m'accroche
c'est de monsieur charles en vérité vous
riez maintenant tu es bien moi ça m'a
digne je sais pas pourquoi mais ça
m'indigne comment distinguera tôt un
homme bialé d'un valet de chambre
car remarqué ma tante qu'il est tout à
fait bien de sa personne
et lorsqu'il vous sert à table qu'il
vous offre à fruits c'est avec un choix
de termes un accent de bonne compagnie
qui me met hors de moi parce qu'il ya de
la pertinence à lui à s'exprimer comme
ses maîtres
c'est vrai cela nous déconsidère cela
nous enfin je ne sais pas comment vous
exprimer ce que je ressens mais moi qui
suivit à veillon pour tout le monde
j'éprouve pour cet insolent valait une
antipathie qui va jusqu'à la version
et si j'étais maîtresse ici bien
certainement il y resterait pas là là là
calmons nous avant de le chasser il faut
permettre qu'il s'explique ce garçon
mais ma tante et ce public vous sonnez
précisément charlet tina les malades un
compte
ils viennent mais maintenant de calais
vous lui dire plus de temps que je ne
voudrais pas qu'ils trient que c'est à
cause de moi de vous demander mais
pourquoi donc ne trouves tu pas qu'il
t'a manqué de respect madame rappelé oui
approchez-vous charles on ne forcerait
donc toujours à vous adresser des
reproches
pourquoi vous êtes-vous permis je savais
pas que j'étais là vous pourquoi vous
êtes-vous permis de vous approcher de
mon portrait du dessin de même
et de dire qu'il était charmant j'ai dit
qu'il était ressemblant madame la
comtesse ski la même chose
c'est précisément ce mot qui est de trop
a prouvé ses juges et et vous n'avez pas
le droit de juger
je demande pardon à mademoiselle de
l'avoir offensé
à l'avenir je ne fais plus que pense et
ce que j'ai dit et je ne dirai plus que
je pense c'est bien du tout c'est mal
voilà encore une de ces dépenses qui
m'exaspère allez-vous préparer la jeune
ponette de mon frère comme je vous
l'avais demandé
et bien ma soeur léonie le temps est
beau vingt mètres et on habite du cheval
et usr à la peau n'attend pas avec vous
maintenant avec mon frère et charles
vous suivra mais il est fort habile
cavaliers son habileté rassure ma
tendresse pour toi
givet ma tante ans je le déteste
[Rires]
fred ont jamais résonna non avis et ça
gronde et moi vous gronder si bien ne
désarmaient pas part aux cages algérie
vous exposer sans cesse à être
découverts ou par leoni ou même par un
de mes gens allaient chanter un air de
cimarosa dans le parc et le chantait
bien encore des pannes ce n'est pas ma
faute je me rappelais toutes vos
inflexion taisez vous bouffe latrines
sont insupportables ingrat je ne parle
pas seulement pour moi qui vous aime
comme une soeur mais pour votre pauvre
mère vous avez raison
voyons que dois-je faire d'abord
répondre quand j'appelle charles et ne
plus dire quoi quand quelqu'un dit rory
la vérité qui n'évoque jamais fini plus
vous extasier devant le dessin
yes et ne pas répondre comme tout à
l'heure je ne ferai plus que pense et ce
que j'ai dit il veut créer ne peut pas
se peut pas s'empêcher sienne pas être
charmant enfin ne pas vous exposer comme
vous l'avez fait ce matin encore malgré
ma défense
en allant à lyon mais malheureuse enfant
vous ne comprenez donc pas qu'il s'agit
de vos jours bon il nous est à craindre
depuis l'arrivée du baron de montrichard
le baron de mouiller le baron amédée
boussard de montrichard oui le nouveau
préfet la la finesse d'une femme il est
rusé comme un diplomate
et avec s'activent persévérant et penser
que c'est un mois peut-être qu'il doit
sa nomination
vous vous conteste vous avez fait nommer
un homme comme lui des frais pendant 20
ans corgémont consulat et l'empiré
toujours pour ça il a toujours été
dévoué corps et âme à tous les
gouvernements établi il espère d'autant
mieux qu'il va faire oublier les
services rendus à leurs prédécesseurs
de tout temps les hommes politiques ont
été des caméléons aussi va-t-il vouloir
signalé son installation par quelques
actions d'éclat
c'est à dire en faisant fusillé deux ou
trois pauvres diables qui n'en peuvent
mais non il n'est pas cruel au contraire
je sais même qu'ils avaient demandé une
amnistie générale mais l'idée de
découvrir un chef de conspirateurs va le
mettre en veille ils dépouillent il
déploiera vôtre vous toutes les
ressources de son esprit votre
signalement sera partout je le sais le
premier soldat pourrez vous reconnaitre
vous l'avouerez j'étais donc dans ses
pires il donc dans cette vie de deux
conspirateurs poursuivi je ne sais quoi
qui m'amuse comme un roman et rien ne me
dit qu'à pied autant que d'entendre
prononcé mon nom dans les marchés lui
que d'acheter aux prieurs des rues la
condamnation que d'interroger un
gendarme qui pourrait mettre la main sur
le connaît et de lui parler de moi toro
pardon monsieur le gendarme s'est
enrichie lavignolle est-ce qu'il n'ait
pas encore pris et et non vraiment au
bassin gaillard qui tient la vie à ce
qu'il paraît aux dites moi un peu son
signalement si vous l'avez mais vous me
fait frémir
oh les sens n'ont toujours les mêmes
n'ayons jamais que leur vanité en tête
vanité de courage ou vanité d'esprit et
bien tenez vous punir
voyez cette lettre de votre mère dit
vous si vous étiez condamnée elle
m'aurait de votre mort a ajouté que si
je vouvoyais arrêtés chez eux ici je
croirais presque être la cause de votre
perte et que j'aurai tout à la fois le
désespoir du regret et le désespoir du
remords allez vous n'avez pas de coeur
alors pardon pardon j'ai tort oui quand
notre existence inspire de tels
sympathie est de nous être sacré je me
défendrai je veillerai sur moi pour ma
mère est pour pour ma soeur anna bonheur
voilà un mot qui efface un peu moteur
pensant à votre salon et pour que je
puisse agir un côté mois ce qui vous a
changé malgré vous aux conspirateurs
le voici et d'abord je vous jure je n'ai
jamais conspirer et je ne construirai
jamais parce que j'ai horreur de la
guerre civile
et quand un français tire sur un autre
français c'est au coeur de la france
elle même qu'ils frappent les en cas de
guerre civile
j'aimerais engagerait dans l'armée bref
il ya un mois pourtant au moment où
venait d'éclater la conspiration du
capitaine sanders
j'entre un matin à lyon je vois ranger
sur la place bellecour un peloton
d'infanterie
avant même que j'aie pu demander quel
exécution s'apprêtait arrive une voiture
deux places suivies de carabiniers à
cheval
les gens voient descendre entre deux
soldats un vieillard cheveux blancs en
grand uniforme et je reconnais qu'ils ce
n'était pas mon ancien général le brave
contre vilgrain du moulin vous le
connaissez du tout
le brave compte il dans la démo
naquirent suva blessure au service de
notre pays
je mélange prions pour l'année sur cette
place pour le fusiller non non non
c'était bien pis encore pour le dégradé
ont été coupables jeu l'ignorent mais
quelques crimes politiques tepa mais un
brin sonore ne dégrade pas connu
oui aussi quand je vis un jeune
commandant arraché à ceux déjà sa
décoration je ne me reconnais plus moi
même je m'élançais dire mon ancien
général et lui remet dans la croix que
j'avais reçues de sa main je mets
criaient vive l'empereur saisies arrêter
comme chef de conspiration je serai un
peu en prison
ou plutôt je n'y serai plus si un de mes
geôliers gagné par vous nous avez donné
les moyens de fuir ici ou chez une
royaliste mon ennemi ici où j'ai le
double bonheur d'être sauvés et d'être
sauvé par on voit la montre est dit
votre gloire henry s'était bien résolue
ce matin vous sauver mais maintenant
qu'ils viennent vous chercher auprès de
moi
nous voici maintenant suis-je via oui ma
chère enfant très bien ta cravate un peu
moins haute voix la ciao ciao opa - oui
allez voir si mon frère est prête
oui
et a donné cette vallereau messieurs de
grignon je n'ai pas encore vu
d'aujourd'hui notre cher aux ils montent
par le grand portail je les laissais au
bas du perron admirant le cheval de mon
oncle quelle belle mal quelques cigares
a appris à être heureux de se sentir
emporté sur cet ouragan vivant est
curieux c'est qu'il le croire vava du
label nature ça nous n'avions pas perdu
l'amanite l'héroïsme je vous entendez là
tout à l'heure je parie vous regretter
de n'avoir pas montée du cfaa non c'est
vrai mais après c'est si beau si vous ne
trouvez pas le second d'adjectifs je me
rende le service de vous interrompre
tenez vous avez là des journaux et des
lettres pour - oui sur la table sur la
terre nul cela je veux pas bien sûr
c'est une halle de l'ena monsieur de
kermadio le faire eux-mêmes et aux
ordres de manuel lait onil gonthier je
vais te mettre à cheval et à nous il
n'est pas là monsieur lisez attentat
lors cette réunion nom auquel est le
mauvais génie qui m'a mis au caire une
passion insensé pour cette femme une
femme qui a été héroïque en vendée une
femme qui adore le courage
aussi faut lui plaire il est pas
d'action intrépide que je ne rêve pas de
péril auquel je ne m'expose en
imagination
dès que je la vois je me croira héros
moi moi un maître des requêtes qui par
mon état ne suis pas obligé et quand je
dis un héros c'est que je le suis en
théorie par malheur il n'en est pas tout
à fait de même dans la pratique c'est
c'est inconcevable c'est inouï
il y a là un mystère qui ne peut
s'expliquer que par des raisons de deux
naissances c'est dans le petit dans le
sang je tiens à la fois à la fois de ma
mère qui était le courage en personne
est à la fois de mon de mon père qui
était la prudence mais les imbéciles me
diront à cela et bien monsieur restait
toujours le fils de votre père
n'approchez pas du danger mais est ce
que je le peux à monsieur est ce que ma
mère me le prêt ne me permets monsieur 1
est-ce que ce soit à l'horizon quelques
actions d'héroïsme le maudit démons
maternelle qui s'agitent en moi ne
précipite pas mal à regarder pendant le
compromettantes
est ce que ma moitié héroïque ne s'offre
pas ne s'engage pas comme tout à l'heure
à la pluie tout beau cheval fougueux et
écume homme que je rêvais l'enfourcher
parce qu'un autre était dessus
eh oui si l'on m'avait dit montella les
montées le vin alors on l'autre moitié
la moitié paternel l'aurait emporté
et adieu ma réputation a au téléphone
offre est au bras et nerveux mais songez
que pour combler deux mots nous voilà
amoureux fou d'une femme dont la vue
m'anime ex at elle elle me fera faire
quelques exploits quelques sorties dans
suis sûr pour l'instant je n'en suis
assez bien tiré
je n'ai eu à dépenser que des paroles
mais cela ne durera peut-être pas et
alors et alors repoussé mais brive et
par là le seul moyen d'en sortir c'est
de l'épouser suivez mon raisonnement
une fois mariée je suis père une fois
père j'ai le droit d'être prudent avec
honneur que dis-je le droit c'est un
devoir
un père de famille se doit à sa femme et
à ses enfants un bonapartiste insulte au
droit devant moi
je ne peux pas le provoquer je suis père
de famille qu'il arrive une un incendie
une peste une inondation quoi je me
sauve
je suis père de famille il faut donc se
hâter d'être père de famille le plus tôt
possible et pour cela risquons la
déclaration une déclaration bien chaude
bien brûlante comme cela sembla voyons
voyons voir nanananère
on amuse rien une année la neige pour
toujours et elle amy n'a ni nenê notre
union
mélanie mines indiqué la mairie de
grignon
voilà voilà voilà plats sont là ici
voilà sous ce sous ce miroir oh oui oui
la berra la girard espère où elle a
prélevé au que se passe-t-il donc un
accident mais commence à reprendre c'est
sans elle elle n'est pas blessée nom
grâce au ciel mais je craque la secousse
l'émotion s'en aller dans mon ami je
vous prie l'un que désirez-vous qu'on a
eu tout de suite à sa tante de la jeune
médecin avec konami ils vont tous réglés
et je vais moi même et je ramène
j'accepte vous êtes devant je suis bon
c'est vrai j'aime autant ne pas être là
quand elle lira ma déclaration brave
mais prudent je pars et je reviens je
pars et je reviens
[Applaudissements]
m'attends pas tant qu est-ce que c'est
un fusil une aventure si étonnant ou
plutôt si heureuse
imaginez-vous m'attendre que charles
monsieur henri tu sait tous que oui sans
doute yeux je tairai je me tairai je
vous aiderai à le protéger à le défendre
c'est sylviane obligés maintenant ne fût
ce que par reconnaissance et tout cela
ne m'explique pas c'est juste
voilà donc vous gallo pire dans le parc
avec mon oncle quand tout à coup son
cheval cropper la planète en fait autant
il m'apporte du côté du bois au déjà
magique s'était accroché à un arbre
j'allais être arraché une nacelle et qui
sait peut être traîné sur la route quand
tout à coup
charles monsieur charles se précipite à
terre sujet tardivement au devant de la
ponette l'arête d'une mam retient de
l'autre et me déposa moitié évanoui sur
le gazon et malgré cela j'étais d'une
colère je lui en voulais te sauver non
pas de me sauver mais ne sauver avec si
peu de respect imaginez-vous ma tante
qui me prenaient les mains pour me les
réchauffer et qui veut répétait sans
cesse comme il l'aurait fait pour son
égal aux enfants pauvres enfants
je ne pouvais pas répondre j'étais
évanoui à mais j'étais très en colère en
dedans et lorsqu en ouvrant les yeux je
le trouvais à mes genoux presque aussi
pâle que moi et qui me tendit la nor me
disant eh bien h à mademoiselle comment
vous trouvez vous
mon indignation fut tel que je répondis
par un coup de cravache je frappais la
maquilleuse aime tant je fonds 10 ans là
sans savoir pourquoi
c'est bien après après juger de ma
surprise et de ma joie quand je vis se
relever en souriante découvrir sa tête
avec une grâce charmante et me dire
simplement après m'avoir salué que votre
légitime orgueil ne s'alarme pas de ma
témérité et mademoiselle celui qui a osé
tendre la main à mademoiselle léonie de
ville gonthier ce n'est pas charles le
valet de chambre c'est monsieur henri de
flat vignolles le proscrit la
malheureuse se perdra comment se perdre
parce qu'il m'a confié son secret qui me
dit que tu seras le garder
vous croyez mon coeur capable de le
trahir le trahir dieu me garde d'un tel
soupçon mais c'est un bon thé même ce
sont tes craintes qui te trahir on ne
redoute et rihanna tente je serai forte
il s'agit de lui de lui
pardonnez-moi mattock je ne puis vous
cacher ce qui se passe dans mon âme
mais d'ailleurs pourquoi vous le cacher
à vous eh bien oui une force une joie
ineffable remplisse mon corps tout
entier
j'étais si malheureuse des pics à ce
jour je ne pouvait m'expliquer à moi
même ce que je ressentais ou plutôt je
n'osais pas c'était de la honte de la
colère je me sentais entraîner vers un
abîme est cependant j tomber avec joie
que veux tu dire je comprends tout
maintenant si j'étais aussi indigné
contre lui et contre moi c'est que je
l'aimais je vois clair dans mon coeur à
présent vous l'aimez qu'avez-vous dont
vous l'aimez vous semble irrité contre
moins chère tante hérité je suis pas il
était cher liesse pourquoi sera géré et
et juniors peut-être est-ce de ma
confiance trop tardive
je vous aurais dit mon secret plutôt si
je l'avais su plus tôt mais qui vous
reprochent votre manque de confiance là
c'est moi seul ou non vous les laissez
moi vous dis-je
mais vous n'avez jamais parlé à si vous
ne me dit plus tu on part dans mon
enfant pendant dix mois maman je t'en
prie faites à la bonne heure au moins
ma tante comme c'est beau d'aimer
[Applaudissements]
elles l'aiment
pourquoi ne l'aimerait tempo voilà la
question n'est-elle pas jeunes comme lui
riche et noble comme lui pourquoi dont
souffrait jetant de cette pensée
pourquoi pendant qu'elle me parle elle
ressentait contre elle un sentiment de
colère d'aversion de nous non c'est pas
possible
depuis treize jours ne veillait jeta sur
henry comme une amie ne lui parlez pas
comme une mère ce matin encore ne laisse
pas remercier de ce qu'il m'appelait
massa or malgré moi le voit-on ce
langage maternelle n'était qu'une ruse
de mon coeur pour ne rien cacher de ma
tendresse ce n'est pas de l'intérêt de
l'amitié du dévouement
c'est de l'amour j'ai
j'aime moi et ma rivale c'est l'enfant
de mon coeur c'est l'enfant de ma soeur
cet état de grâce et de beauté je me
parle à moi même et je me réponds tu
n'as qu'une résolution à prendre cécile
cécile c'est moi renferme renferme folle
passion dans ton coeur comme il est
autre qu à celle là est tout
je ne peux pas
depuis que je me suis imprégné de
l'amour à moi-même et croît chaque
pensée à chaque parole
je le sens qu'ils m'ont envahi comme un
flou qui monte qui monte qui monte qui
monte eh bien pourquoi le convoque les
audi et mme henry c'est vrai mais lui il
ne l'aiment pas encore
suivez mon raisonnement il aurait parlé
s'il l'aimait elle me l'aurait dit s'il
avait parlé il est libre et qu'elle
choisisse elle est bien belle déjà on
dit que je le suis encore qu'il prononce
pauvre enfant elle aime tant mais je
laime mille fois davantage
elle aime comme on aime à saison quand
on a l'avenir devant soi mais à 30 ans
notre amour à notre vie tout entière
allons il foule était lu ton on dit que
j'ai de l'esprit servons nous ans léonie
à 16 ans qu'elle se défende et si je
triomphe aujourd'hui je réponde l'avenir
je rendrai henry si heureux que son
bonheur maps ou draps du miey mettrions
frej suis-je aussi charmante qu'elle qui
me la prendre quand on a un grand nom du
crédit de la fortune ce qui nous entoure
distille la vérité
mam étrangle en prenant ce miroir ce
n'est pas le trouble de la coquetterie
non c'est mon coeur qui fait trembler
maman c'est pas invraisemblable vraiment
mon coeur qui fait trembler ma main
je me trouverai jamais tel que je
voudrais êtes ne regardons pas le
regarderont on ne regarde le rush pas
aller je me regarde ces charmants
jeunes à tromper bientôt à madame la
conte et cécile d'autres vannes et de
kermadio c'est moi de monsieur gustave
de grignon et bien lison
j'arrive de saint andéol le médecin
était malade cet instinct monde
formation aux élites y tient mal être
chez lui elle ne semble pas trop irrité
oui oui c'est bien langage derrière nous
et le puy que la passion au elles se
parlent est le même vous avez remarqué
et même on peut nommer mais encore ils
demandent ma main on peut dans son giron
m'épouser encore en ma foi je me risque
est-ce vous qui avez écrit cette lettre
cette lettre c'est elle que tout à
l'heure à mon dieu et vieillesse ou non
oui oui c'est moi oui et ce qu'elle
contient bien l'accent de votre passion
certainement font dès maintenant
demander ma mère les deux contestent les
données de pourquoi pas oui vous l'avez
fait que la valeur n'attend pas le
nombre des années et qu'elle porte l'âge
tout ce que je peux vous dire tout ce
que je sais tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que c'est que vous êtes jeune
et belle ce que je sais c'est que je
vous aime vous m'aimez oui et du si vous
ne pas me pardonner du ciron en juin
vouloir mon ami mon véritable ami et si
c'est vrai vous me trouvez belle à
jamais par a noté christine douce
aussi je pouvais vous dire si vous aimez
je ne vous demande pas tant l'émotion le
tout doux je vous vois suffirait à me
faire perdre la raison
qu'est-ce que cela j'oubliais et
j'oubliais est une surprise c'est une
fête vous pouvez oublier
nous y pensions nous et votre nièce et
là dans le grand salon vos amis les
habitants du village tous vos sens et
sandwichs au pâté conserve à la cancer
il sera là oh merci mon ami dans son oui
madame dans son domaine ambulanciers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est étonnant ce étonnant depuis l'aveu
qu'elle m'a fait elle ne me regarde plus
et pourtant quand je me rappelle son
trouble de ce matin sa physionomie two
to me dit que je suis mais oui tous
voulaient que vous tous excepté l
afrique ne l'êtes passionnés des paroles
brûlante ne suffisent pas à la
compréhension de l'amour il faudrait des
preuves réelles des actions
un beau dragon
[Applaudissements]
dans gagnol c'est moi mes ordres soit
exécutée de pointer en coin
rien de plus rien de moins rien de plus
rien de moins
j'entends des jeunes femmes rentraient
ghalioune je rends grâce à dieu
oui chapeau chacun chapeau
la gouache cécile de travail de
carmagnole elle est au salon monsieur
environné de tous ses amis dont elle
reçoit des bouquets c'est ça fait
d'ailleurs vous entendez la musique
mais dès qu'elle sera que monsieur le
préfet du département est arrivé
connaissait monsieur nom de nous mais je
viens d'entendre prononcer votre nom et
je cours de grâce monsieur et ne veut
rien ne presse
quand on est porteur et fâcheuse
nouvelle mon dieu la comtesse que je
connais depuis longtemps a toujours été
parfaite pour moi et dernièrement encore
monsieur le marquis de mots peloter
ministre de l'intérieur ne m'a pas
laissé ignorer qu'elle avait parlé en ma
faveur
elle est fort bien en cours et je
conçois qu'il vous soit fini pour la
première visite que je lui fais de lui
apporter une mauvaise nouvelle
plusieurs messieurs une surtout qui est
fâcheuse
le feu vient de prendre une des firmes
de la comtesse vous en être certain
absolument nous l'avons aperçue en
passant sur les droits août et comme je
ne pouvais détachées ou cas des gens de
mon escorte pour des motifs et des
mortiers multiples ont des motifs
sérieux monsieur tu diriges et sur la
ferme tous les paysans nous avons
rencontré en chemin ordonnant qu'on
m'apporte pas ou plutôt des nouvelles de
l' incendie faisceaux d'ions en rond en
quelques belles occasions d'héroïsme si
j allais au en lui quelque l effet sur
la côte est
quand elle demandera où donc est
monsieur degrés nous et pour lui
répondent
il est sur le feuillet hier au feu au
feu pour vous conter sens monsieur cette
ferme était loin d'ici à une demi lieue
à fait pas si l'on pouvait surveiller
une pompe
une pompe une faune par incendie à la
provence en oil
il y en a une à la ville voisine
monsieur je pouvais raconter
peut-être ne vous appauvrir et en
passant un ordre signé de voir bien
mettez tous peur ne continueront pas
n'importe qui mais thil plus beaux rôles
celui de sauveur dans un incendie
quand je vous le demande au marché et
marché sur les poutres d'enflammer
qu'elle soit disparaître au milieu d'un
tourbillon de fumée et de feu ont le
plus terrible par la toiture à s'écouler
hockey l'extase voir tout à coup à une
fenêtre gia bon tout à coup à une
fenêtre un bon viard
une femme qui tend vers voulait france
et criant sauvez moi et c'est l'ancien
au milieu des cris de la foule
n'y allez pas vous allez vous perdre la
porte au monsieur monsieur le ferme y at
il des enfants droit trois enfants devra
avoir en réserve
oui tant mieux c'est moi nous enveloppe
c'est plus facile à sauver à et puis et
puis rendre trois enfants alors meira
comme la comtesse le recevoir
quand je reviendrai escorté par tous les
hommes de la ferme porté sur un brancard
de free iron man les vêtements déchirés
le visage mois-ci exact données me suis
donné je vous voyez monsieur prendre des
nouvelles de ce garçon nous avons
rencontrés sur la route est convenable
et c'est le lieu de la sortie comment
blessé a blessé les seuils blessé
légèrement sans doute hélas non monsieur
brûler la peau lui tombé du visage à la
la la la peau lui tomber la pluie tombée
mais le plus dangereux c'est une poutre
il veut enfoncer cinq autres
à enfoncer cinq côtes oui voyez vous
cela
et en voulant porter secours vouloir
mais allez messieurs année mais mais je
vais je suis parti le temps de faire
c'est les mots cheval parlement
domestique qui en même temps pourrait
bien tirer lui-même car dès qu'il s'agit
de porter une lettre cela le regarde que
moi je leur ai fait un exploit est
arrivé annonçant que le feu était attend
mieux et un mois
quelle fatalité au moment où j allais
car vous l'avez vu j'y allais je partais
un instant je partais le sous-lieutenant
a passé tous nous sommes à l'extérieur
comme vous l'aviez indiqué mais il a de
nouveaux renseignements dont ils
voudraient faire pas à monsieur le
préfet le tient à les connaître et à les
vérifier moi-même avant d'avoir vu la
pontaise motus messieurs veuillez ne pas
parler de mon arrivée à vannes avec la
comtesse des motifs sérieux m'oblige à
vous quitter
mais je reviens à l'instant il revient
est stable vers gagne jamais une
occasion pareille un incendie que je
réprouve et éteindre de l'héroïsme était
pas de danger à 6 à mes jambes contrent
à l'autre devrait toujours la ponte
la comtesse la comtesse toujours rêveuse
comme ce matin tablent eux elle elle
pense à moi madame assez vous mon cher
de grignon elle a dit mon cher et
cugnaux et bien vous attendez tous pas
dans la salle de bain à laval gens
pètent au milieu du salon le château et
la ferme grand seigneur et femme de
chambre mais tu te j'y suis mais tom la
coûteuse surtout si l'occupant de vos
intérêts une de vos fermes où le feu a
pris mais s'il est éteint par malheur
pour voir comment ça bonjour et tenter
m'exposer j'aurais tenté même exposé
pour vous car sachez le bien je vous
aime plus que moi même je vous ai
compris que ma vie c'est beaucoup vous
en doutez vous bien et bien je le crois
mais plus que la vie non vous n'assistez
seulement pas notre concert en gt madame
j'étais j'ai entendu votre admirable duo
avec votre nièce 1 auquel enthousiasme
général aux gens eux mêmes qu'ils
écoutent et de l'autriche aurait fait un
avis transporté --un surtout votre
nouveau domestiques chat
louis charles richard brava grave a
encore plus fort que moi assesseurs de
grignon que j'accusais que je méconnu
fait je les emmenais au même point de ce
matin elle est à moi ton presque
vous les charbons m'applaudissent il ya
tellement ri comme on avait eu des torts
envers vous je veux les réparer allait
m'attendre dans le salon nous y dans son
ensemble oui madame chic courges
courgettes en haleine comme cela va
quand il sent que ça va bien aller au
bout
pardon monsieur ma tante plus qu'ils
habitent et pour la prochaine contre
odense par monsieur henri et bien tu dis
papa c'est qu'auparavant j'aurai un
conseil à vous demander comment je vais
vous dire j'ai chanté tout à l'heure
n'est ce pas oui et bien pendant que je
chantais j'ai vu des larmes dans ses
yeux à lui henri et c'est déjà un bon
commencement
cela prouve au moins que je ne lui
déplaît pas n'est ce pas ma tante en
deux mais ce qui m'a pris et lui faire
vis-à-vis et j'ai une grande peur que la
danse ne vienne détruire le bon effet de
montchamp j'ai envie de ne pas danser
qui penses tu mais je tente des fonds
dans son île et encore vous me disiez
trop de raideurs dans les bras les
épaules pas assez facile malgré tout
c'est sûrement sous vraiment que trop
on attend mieux tant que je fais danser
m'attendent et puis sa chaîne de
corriger et la première fois que je
dansais avec lui ce qui retardera pas je
l'espère mais bien quitte retient un
autre conseil que j'aurais à vous
demander s'ils ne parlent en dansant que
lui dirais-je j'ai peur de rester coûts
réduits paraître sont pas mon silence en
attente
conseillez moi donnez moi un sujet de
conversation ou rat que vous avez tant
d'esprit et votre esprit me plaisent
tant il te l'a dit pendant plus d'un
quart d'heure ainsi il me semble que des
paroles inspirées par vous garderez
quelque chose de votre grâce à ses yeux
que le zinc il y repenser mais j'y suis
oui oui voilà un sujet de conversation
je suis certaine de lui plaire je
parlerai de quoi de vous avant sur ces
chapitres l'as répondre d'éloquence à la
bonne tendre nature
je crois entendre la voix de monsieur
henry henry
quand il est là je ne vois plus que lui
il m'attend il me semble qu'il m'appelle
à dieu m'accorde indien
[Musique]
elle le rejoint la contreuse commence il
est vis-à-vis d'elle comme il la regarde
mais ils oublient que c'est à lui de
danser ils traversent ils lui donnent la
main mais carnage
elle pallie la consternation se placent
sur son visage mais que dis-je sur tous
les visages
mais à nice et lens henri s'élance dans
la cour et on y revient mais qu'as tu
que tu vends du sien capsules des
soldats des dragons des soldats sentant
le château et déjà l'envié d'entraîner
recours mais c'est impossible
il s'est arrêté cet homme a su gagner en
arrêter je ne conteste d'autres d'amener
de kermadio c'est impossible que du
calme du calme et tu tiens vous pouvez
en avoir d'accord toutes les portes je
crois bon s'il est en péril il verra vie
à laquelle de nous des bleus plus que la
fin de ce s
ça vous dirait quand on pourra vous
vient me badd bien eu lieu eh bien ce
sont effectivement des dragons qui me
cherche d'offres et dragons qui voulait
un prix l'officier lui même que j'ai
interrogés adroitement ou comment avez
vous osé mais il me semble que ça
m'intéresse ainsi pour que je m'en
informe maraka vous at-il dit qu'ils
venaient pour arrêter monsieur henri de
la vigne est assez clair ça me semble
perdu mais ce que le malheur peut
m'atteindre entre vous deux il dit vrai
à nous de vaisseau vers permettait
permet cannes ou trois je demande aussi
en être voyons cherchons quelques bons
déguisements l'a bien original en tout
genre du roman en connaissez vous un
plus charmant à nos bons noms de grands
des pages
je mets souvent aux façons d'abord
quelles sont nos ennemis mais mon
colonel
comment se nomme l'officier des dragons
d'âge ligne hommes en général mais est
accompagné du nouveau préfet le terrible
parents mourichon terrible enchanteur
des coupes en battant bordeaux par ainsi
malheureusement
je ne peux pas m'en défaire même que la
faille à la presse pas comme toi mais je
pense à lui
la douleur me donne du courage elle est
belle ou inattendus et chevet scellier
elle est touchante en gros danger je te
paye commande non non mais gronde et moi
gros des mois je dirais toujours au
monde angers jeune benni mais sans lui
vous verrez ce que deux à mes côtés me
plaignant me défendant viennent à 100
ans elle-même je ne regretterai pas
puisque grâce à elle je puis vous
inspirer à vous tendre frayeur à vous
tendre courage c'est insupportable avait
beau madrigaux et pensons baron s'ils
osent venir ici c'est qu'on nous a
trahis c'est qu'il sait tout oui mais
qui dans ce que ma tête est mise à prix
ce que ma capture vaut une trahison
il ya des gens qui trahissent pour rien
il y à dos ou encore du désintéressement
silence on vient monsieur le baron
amédée boussard de montrichard qui se
présentaient chez la comtesse cécile
d'autres valent mes deux kermadio fait
demander s'il veut bien fallu faire
l'honneur de le recevoir
ciel certainement avec plaisir le baron
caire y allait décider encore payé
monsieur filles et entrèrent qu'il reste
j'avais une idée
non pas encore mais il faut que vous
restiez que monsieur nourrichard vous
voit vous va comme domestiques
on soupçonne plus difficilement ce qu'on
a dû d'abord sans les soupçonner c'est
vrai que vous êtes heureuse la barre
temps de présence d'esprit ma tante
comment faites-vous dont je meurs
d'angoise ma fille alors éloigne toi il
faut que je sois seul avec le baron seul
n'ont pas n'ont pas je veux savoir ce
que vous lui direz vous bien entendu sa
main qui vendent sur le baron amédée
boussard de montrichard monde je suis
heureuse de vous voir leurs livres de la
comtesse vous adresser mes remerciements
pour votre préfecture
eh bien je les mairies
vous aviez un adversaire redoutable mais
ge est en cavale et tend à briguer car
vous m'avez fait faire des choses dont
je rougis que je fini par l'emporter que
de graves devront mais qui a pu me
valoir
ainsi honorable patronage notre mérite
d'abord bien sûr c'est évident oui mais
au jeu vous caennais de plus longue date
que vous ne le pensez nous avons fait la
guerre l'un contre l'autre en vendée il
vous m'avez protéger quoi tu ennemis et
encore à titre d' ennemi je vous contrer
cela un de ces jours quand vous restez
cham chab aller chercher des
rafraîchissements pour monsieur le baron
vous combler oui je veux vendre la
reconnaissance très difficile
bâillements eh bien je crois que je
viens de trouver le moyen de m'acquitter
vis-à-vis de vous commencez déjà comment
en maintenant le plaisir de vous
recevoir
je viens vous offrir à vous madame qui
est si dévouée à la bonne cause
l'occasion de rendre signalé service à
sa majesté
donnez moi la main à baron voilà le
monde un vrai royalistes et ce service
c'est de faire arrêter le chef de la
grande conspiration de la partie ce chef
est donc un homme connu importants
connus bien sûr enfin du moins de vous
est ce que je crois à conteste mais moi
je connais un conspirateur de nom de ce
traître qui m'a trompé monsieur henri de
flaminio elle monsieur henri de flavie
gueule ce tout jeune homme qui à lurcy
tout jamais tout seul lui
j'ai vu quelques fois chez sa mère
mais sans effet eh bien je dis comme le
fameux show rance il est bon à partir je
ne connais plus je crois que je fais le
vert un peu long des normales ne le
pardonnons thil dont ce monsieur de la
vignole il se cache dans un château dans
un château voisin pré voisin où vous
allez surprend voilà difficile car il me
faudrait votre aide pour cela à madame
imaginer que ce château appartient à une
femme du plus haut rang du plus pur
royalisme une femme de coeur d'esprit et
de plus ma bienfaitrice comme par
excisées mans alors imaginez mona omar a
que pour lui dire d'abord la soupçonne
ensuite que je viens faire chez elle une
domiciliaire et enfin vous l'avouerez
que j'ai compter sur vous pour la
prévenir
si vous pensez comme moi je rase elle un
conspirateur non je ne le crois pas non
j'en suis sûr et c'est pour ça que vous
avez amené tout cet attirail de dragon
vous avez déployé ce luxe de gendarmerie
mon dieu oui je ne sortirai pas d'ici
avant d'avoir arrêté l'ennemi du roi
il faut bien conteste que je vous prouve
ma reconnaissance
bien moins marrant je vous prouverait
comment une femme offensée se venge nous
venger a procédé inqualifiable d'une
sanglante injure pour une fervente
royalistes comme moi à monsieur le baron
vous venez vous attaquez chez moi dans
mon château pour préfet qu'elle vit vous
allez parcourir pour fouiller latéraux g
et surtout de la défiance défier vous de
mes larmes défier le mans sourire quand
je pars et joyeuse penser que je suis
inquiète
à moins que je ne prévois c'est de
prévoyance et que je ne veuille a
déconcerté par un double calcul
ravissant servait j'avais des
rafraîchissements monsieur le baron au
lieu de marmonner prenez défense baron
prenez vous en aurez besoin
bien que faites vous là avec vos bras
pendants et votre mine bêtement réjouit
servait dont les sous genres que nos
gens à du marron as-tu ou plutôt mois
des montres à mme paula les doutes qui
commence à me prendre et si on m'avait
trompé si monsieur de flaminio elle
n'était pas ici aussi je le ballon
désire-t-il tout à l'heure s'ils y
étaient la comtesse auraient-elles ce
ton insultant et railleur sur le ballon
mais tout à l'heure que dis-je
oui mais s'il n'y est pas mon expédition
va me couvrir de ridicule
sans compter que le crédit de la
comtesse est considérable et qu'elle
peut me perdre pas si je repartais oui
mais si une heure après mon départ
madame la comtesse franchir la frontière
à monsieur leflaive miaule sans l'effet
de ma réputation
j'en ai la tête on fumera ben ça tombe
bien si monsieur le ballon voulait dire
soins d'idées des l'infléchissement mais
va-t-on au diable rhodia givel jeu le
monde attend ni des approches rien de
moi dans les yeux aux joueuses de l'est
pas mais non mais non
mais toi mon ami lapointe a nié que le
paraissait si le ballon est bien vous
les riffs assassins il fait beau chaud
c'est à demeurer c'est un imbécile
non merci dites moi mon ami votre
maîtresse vous a bien mal traitée tout à
l'heure mamette aux dames
owusu mais souvent à ce régime
mais tous les jours monsieur le ballon
et qu'on vient vous donne-t-elle de
surcroît de gage pour ce supplément de
mauvaise humeur
ready to ainsi maltraité mal payé mon
gars tu gagnes et 25 femmes
oui monsieur le var mais comment
monsieur de favignolles doit être caché
dans le château haut peuvent le type
autre chose alors si tu pouvais le
découvrir il me le montrer je te
donnerai anne saint louis 25 oui rien
que pour vous montrer et là pourquoi riz
tu sais que c'est de l'argent gagné
tu sais quelque chose beaucoup mais
c'est égal je me trompe pas je vous le
montre le rêve et je te donne un louis
davant
oui au bâtiment payer un examen blanc
datant de peur qu'on le soupçonne de
connivence
la comtesse et syfy aulas laisse je vais
tâcher de me faire infecter par madame à
votre service pour laisse parler plus
facilement tous les deux hommes étant un
bien
je vois que je ne me suis pas trompé en
m'adressant à toi je peux tu dois au
neuvième jeu le ballon gage tapissaient
les vents assez les banques sera ça
c'est du vent non je ne prends pas c'est
pas un imbécile semaine idiot
et d'un allié qui demeure dans la place
il vaut mieux un allié demeurer que pas
d'alliés du tout c'est pas maladroit ce
que je viens de faire la ham et suivez
bien mon raisonnement il n'est pas de
citadelle si forte qu'elle ne soit elle
n'est pas cotée faible et vous n'êtes
pas ici madame la comtesse la seule que
l'on puisse attaquer voyons quels sont
les habitants de ce château non monsieur
de kermadio frère de madame la comtesse
personnage muet qu'on n'a pas vu et
qu'on ne verra pas monsieur de grignon
monsieur de grigny en monsieur de
brigneau ça doit être apparent de
monsieur de grignan au président de la
cour prévôtale est un homme de notre
bord il pourra m'être utile arrêtons
nous ici mademoiselle léonie de ville
gauthier nièce de madame la comtesse
lâche peut-elle avoir 16 ou 17 ans
monsieur l'oeuf la vignole 25 ans tout
au plus
sa figure n'est pas encore le
signalement que j'attends lui doit être
beau a proscrit est toujours bon et riom
si mademoiselle léonie l'a vu elle doit
lui porter de l'intérêt et suivez
toujours bien mon raisonnement moan
arrivée doit la faire trembler au à 16
ans quand on tremble on entre à c'est
partant de madame la comtesse bras
quelle femme
je crois que si j'en avais eu temps j'en
viendrais amoureux c'est lcd au mit vous
allez voir ma finesse viendra à bout de
sa naïveté
pardon monsieur baroin je croyais
m'attendre dans sa longue et elle quitta
l'instant mais je serai bien malheureux
si son absence nous est traité par vous
en ennemi mois pour traiter en ennemi
comment messieurs vous éloignant
oh je conçois votre défiance mais ma
défiance
vous pensez que je suis venu ici pour
vous ravir une personne qui vous est
cher c'est un benêt il veut me sondés
mais je fais être fille emma finesse
viendra bout de sa sottise vous allez
voir je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez
dire monsieur mon dieu ce que je veux
dire eh bien ça il ya une heure quand
vous m'avez vu arriver ici suivi
d'hommes armés vous avez pu penser que
j'étais votre ennemi jeu était en effet
puisque je cherchais monsieur henri de
flat vignoles mais maintenant tout est
changé
comment oui je sais j'ai la certitude de
monsieur leflaive ignol n'est pas ici et
je pars fine de suite touché tout de
suite que votre empressement pourrait me
donner du sang comme ambitieux mais oui
à voir si heureuse de mon départ je
pourrais penser que je me suis trompé
et comme monsieur leflaive vignolles et
encore mois heureuse de votre départ au
contraire monsieur le baron est
certainement si vous pouviez vous garder
longtemps très très longtemps
permettez permettez voilà vous tomber
dans l'excès contraire en moselle tout à
l'heure vous voulez me renvoyer un peu
trop vite et maintenant vous voulez me
garder un peu trop longtemps ce qui est
pour une personne soupçonneuse pourrait
bien signifier la même chose je ne
comprends pas monsieur le baron vous
mademoiselle calmez-vous ce sont là de
pure formalité car je sais j'ai la
certitude que puisque le favignolles
n'est pas ou n'est plus dans ce château
et vous avez bien raison monsieur
membres aussi part à petit conscience
pure formalité ne pas avoir déplacé tout
un escadron pour rien n'est ce pas je
vais faire fouiller les bois des
environs
parmi dragon fait monsieur le par bon il
est pas dans les bois film
visitez les combles il n'est pas dans
les combles les tatars et pendant qu là
car les cheminées du château c'est votre
devoir monsieur le baron
bon eh ben il est pas dans le château
finesse interrogés et examinés par ce
que il ya aussi les déguisements
elle appréciait interroger les hommes de
peine
les hommes de peine non les garçons de
ferme
les domestiques 1 il a tremblé
et enfin je m'en irai malheureux puisque
boutique mademoiselle mais heureux
cependant de ne pas avoir accompli ici
mon pénible de voir monsieur qu'elle de
voir monsieur de lavignolle et
militaires vous ne l'ignorez pas et je
devrai envoyé dans le conseil de guerre
un conseil de guerre la mort non pas une
rigoureuse tout au plus mais c'est la
morpho dit vous nous aimez vous aimez
j'en suis certaine la mort pour lui
monsieur je vous le demande a chez nous
il a 25 ans il a une vertu mouras humeur
il a des amis qui vivent que de sa vie
il n'est pas coupable il n'a pas
conspiré il me l'a dit lui même grâce
monsieur ne me condamner fois que le
compte à dépôt aux enfants enfin c'est
mon devoir
savez vous mademoiselle que vous me
parlez comme s'il était en mon pouvoir
il est donc ici ici mais je n'ai pas dit
non mais tout à l'heure quand j'ai parlé
d'interroger les domestiques vous avez
tremblay oui à l'instant même
vous avez tressaillez moi oui et quand
j'ai parlé vous m'avez dit ne l'arrêté
pas nolan
oui je suis sur la trace moi aussi les
dans le château je suis sous un
déguisement silence nous et je vois
votre mémoire votre trouble je
craindrais d'être important aussi je me
répète y faire et surtout qu'ils ne
sortent pas d'ici
il en championnat pas d'enregistrer
je compte sur toi quand tu es ji hwan
henry club comme en wallonie cela comme
on dit chez nous
à sétif où ça c'est chez nous à sa chute
ou chez nous ou alors ils flafla
quelle scène vous n'auriez pas monsieur
ne riez pas ciel
mais quelle douleur sur votre ex
qu'avez-vous un câble et moi monsieur
henri maudit c'est moi je suis une
malheureuse os x sans courage et sans
finesse au nom du ciel que dites vous
vous vous étiez confier à moi vous
m'aviez révélé le secret dont dépend
toute votre vie
et bien ce secret je les livre et je
vous ai trahis
comment ici devant votre juge pas la
semaine aux lâches que je suis j'ai pas
parcours vous ce type aussi loi vous
perdre
moi tu donnerais ma vie pour vous sauver
quant aux anges mais je ne survivrais
pas votre âge vous le sud aussi je vous
demande de pardonner de ne pas m'en
vouloir
les lions nom du ciel à voir mais que
fais tu là où je vis grâce et pardon ma
tante cas c'est pas vrai tout est
découvert par moi que tout est perdu est
perdu perdu non moi je suis là moi oui
maintenant de sauver le ne craignez rien
monsieur de montrichard m'a pris pour
complice on ne visite séparément âge as
tu une secondes suffisent pour éclairer
mais je suis là qu'est ce que cela
signifie le savez-vous contexte qu'est
ce que tous ces bruits de conspiration
de conspirateurs déguisé lève de
monsieur maurice arrêt soit mono temps
d'arrêt tout le château toute la livrée
ciel
on est tous su parfaitement je vais
briser votre domestique mais tenez voici
mon brigade de gendarmerie
ah c'est vous que je cherche vous dois
payer me suivent
monsieur il y avait erreur est attaché
au service particulier de monsieur le
préfet au nom il ya pas mal mais sans de
son précis veuillez me suivre
ne vous ai rien je réponds de tous aller
dont charles hallé obéissent et oui
madame we look madame ici dans un quart
d'heure il faut que je vous parle à vous
seul - silence au rendez vous aux joies
de mieux en mieux entrepreneurs
et c'est moi qu'il perd je vous suis le
pic est perdu par l sauver paroisse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien quelle nouvelle
j'ai exécuté toutes vos instructions
sans les comprendre
c'est pas nécessaire d'un livre de jean
je m'en bats les pieds je les fais
porter comme vous l'aviez dit là dans
cet appartement
mais monsieur de montrichard il a appelé
tour à tour devant lui tous les
domestiques de la maison après les avoir
interrogés les avons gagnées et monsieur
henri il a toujours gardé auprès de lui
c'est mauvais signe à n'être en rien si
un prudent il finira par se trahir
mais vous voulez ferrer bad et ne
verrait pas des enfants où sont les
troupes ennemies
une douzaine de gendarmes dans la cour
du château un une trentaine de dragon
doit autour des fossés et devant la
grande porte très bien
par exemple ils sont oubliés garder la
porte des écuries et des remises qui
donne sur la campagne elle croit je
reconnais bien là monsieur maurice jarre
vous en doutez m'attendre regardez pas
un seul soldat non mais derrière l' aile
du château
ne vois tu pas une embuscade aux vous
avez raison tout de suite à lui son
chapeau galonnés d'un gendarme
quand je te le disais à chaud comprendre
on voulait l'engager à fillon de ce côté
pour mieux le saisir précisément merci
monsieur le baron le moyen est bon il
pourra le servir comment tu toi moi
j'entends monsieur de l'union pas dire
un champ palefrenier de mettre les
chevaux à la calèche natale
le voici madame fidèle au rendez vous
que vous m'avez donné je vous attendais
matin dié elle m'attendait
et tout en vous attendant je rêvais
acquis à vous - vous sur ce caractère
chevaleresque à ce besoin de brancher
qui vous tourmentent j'en conviens mais
comme rien n'est plus contagieux que
l'imagination et que grâce aux barons de
montrichard j'ai l'esprit taux plein de
conspirateurs et d'arrestations je ne
figurais un pauvre proscrit condamné à
mort un mort
et vous étiez le proscrit ah non au
contraire c'est à moi qu'il venait
demander asile
ah oui c'est bien aussi ben oui il
m'apprenait qu'ils avaient une mère une
soeur
oui ça arrive aussi quand soudain voilà
des soldats qui entoure le château et
m'ordonne de leur livrer mon nom de
livret jamais pourquoi nous nous
entendons il me menaçait presque de la
mort mais qu'apporte la mort qu'importe
la mort surtout si celle que l'on que
l'on aime est là pour vous encourager
pour vous bénira conteste qu'on taise
quand je fais quand je fais de tel rêve
avec vous pour témoin mon coeur bat ma
tête s'exalte peut-être parce que c'est
un rêve quoi vous douter qu'en réalité
je promets mais que faut-il donc pour
vous convaincre
ce matin pour vous j'ai failli me jeter
au milieu des flammes ce soir je
voudrais vous voir dans un piège mortel
pour vous à l'arraché ou bien pour le
partager avec vous quelle chaleur d'un
bleu au milieu des flammes
ah oui
pas content n'escomptent s vous ne le
connaissez pas ce coeur qui vous adore
vous ne savez pas de quel sacrifice de
quel tourment l'amour le rendre capable
vous oui oui au pij la magicienne qu'une
prière c'est qu'il m'envoie une occasion
de mourir thon rouge est bien le ciel
nous a entendus merci cette occasion
vous appelleriez il vous l'envoie il me
l'envoie charles oui valet de chambre et
que vous avez vus arrêter n'est pas
charles charles n'est pas fiable
c'est monsieur henri de flaminio envie
de faire mieux sur henry de flat
vignolles condamné à mort comme
conspirateurs syrie et vous pouvait le
sauver
comment en vous mettant sa place est au
pouvoir pour être officiers annonça
n'ira pas jusque là non
et pendant quelques instants seulement
il faudra passer pour lui vous faire
arrêter pour lui un poing de fer n'était
content j'espère météo
non j'ai dit j'ai dit tout pour vous
tous pour vous mais pour un inconnu pour
notre en gnl je ne pourrais pas inscrits
alors j'entends bien dont j'ai fait la
complice donc je dois défendre les jours
au péril des miens et vous hésitez pas
du tout du tout du tout bon non non vous
comprenez bien que pourrait bien que si
je veux si je tremble car je le prends
c'est indéniable
bon c'est vrai c'est pour vous non car
pour moi ça mais bien la différence oui
je le savais bien voici je compte sur
votre héroïne
oui oui c'est ça je tâcherai qu'elles
soient sans péril wells et oui oui son
père il sait bien mais je crois pouvoir
répondre sans péril
oui son père et non ça ne m'intéresse
pas son père ils ont à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire
comme disais non je veux client n'est
dupe et rim
que faut-il faire prendre un avis des
livrets qui est la jaguar est monté sur
le siège de ma calèche au lieu de me
cracher j'ai montré après pendant les
guides et me conduit mal je vous conjure
et où va t-on à 200 pas dit si ou des
gendarmes se jetteront sur nous un bruit
des jaunards à les jaunards les allées
légendaire les quelques gendarmes qui
vous arrêteront mois depuis nyon en
n'ont pas boudé graignon vous de
flavigny et quoi qu'on vous dise quoi
qu'on vous fait vous avouerez vous
soutiendrez que vous êtes henri ii
favignolles et on vous arrêtera
moi de grignon non vous de flavie 2 à
vue et pendant ce temps là le véritable
favignolles passera la frontière
sauvé par vous par votre héroïne tarifs
oui et alors moi pendant ce temps là je
m'avoue en prison je voulais dire oui
c'est bien la prison prison oui oui on
raisonne en plaisir des cachots des
tortures des draps des buts pas trempé
dans l'âme il
les cafards non non bien mais t'es con
tu as perdu 3 alors je vous expliquerai
on vient à éviter des pics la livre est
là oui madame je vais mais je vais vous
allez vous je moi là je vais je vais
prendre la livre est le même c'est pas
de sa faute et c'est par ici
ac/dc juste n'ont pas tenu d'un mur nous
attendait prenez cette lettre je prends
cette lettre huit pour vaud pour
pourquoi feindre la mettre dans votre
livre est oui dans mon livre est
précisément précisément oui dans quel
but vous le saurez elle est toujours je
ne saurais je vais toujours mon premier
coup de sonnette de ceux de sonnettes
vous aviez prépare est oui en livrer
sans doute on vient allait-on allez y et
oui oui je je je vais je vais je les vis
de lui je me suis à mon père ma mère
maintenant soit monsieur nô richard on
vous parlait déjà couru qu'en vie ne se
soit pas trahi et encore voici baron là
comment a t'on ouvrage continuer quoi
servent ils suivent et surtout ses
domestiques qui était toujours avec moi
oui monsieur le préfet en faire gagner
le jour sur cette notion henri saivet la
langue du sang froid
mesdames ses parents
vous venez vous reposer auprès de nous
devons fatigue vous devez en avoir
besoin
merci comptes et biens
où en êtes-vous de vos recherches
avez-vous bien fouillés et interrogés
mais au cours des interrogatoires
comment appelez-vous cet examen de
conscience vous avez fait subir à ma
nièce demoiselle votre nièce ne m'a
appris que ce que je ne savais déjà à
savoir que monsieur henri de flavigny
les cas ces tâches et dans ce château
sous un déguisement sarah déguisement de
femmes peut-être cette allemagne s ou
moi auriez-vous ne me donnerait pas le
chant je regarderai bien fade et vous
vous avez fait là une belle trouvaille à
ça comment allez-vous découvrir le
coupable parmi les 25 30 personnes du
château le chercheur cher et si les
soupçons sont juste ici un peu de temps
c'est tout étoile quand j'aurai les
renseignements que j'attends ciel tu es
toi je pourrais je l'espère le plus vous
importuner par ma présence ne vous n'
est pas et si vous soupçons se trompe ce
qui leur arrive quelquefois veuillez
vous installer ici sans façon sans
cérémonie comme chez vous certainement
mais pour vous laisser toute liberté
dans vos recherches
je vous demanderai la permission d'aller
passer quelques jours à la ville où des
affaires m'appelle vous ma tante tétouan
dont elle veut s'éloigner finesse vous
partez nous est vraiment à moi je sois
prisonnière de mon propre château et
monsieur le préfet une belle pomme
laisser partir on peut le penser c'est
un mois devait lire et à vous de
commandes et j'avais d'avant s'il est la
permission en commun dans mes shows sont
ils appelés oui maintenant bien pourquoi
ne l'at-on pas d'avertir la comtesse de
madame la voiture étant maintenant
aventure madame la comtesse été rossés a
bien appelé ma femme de chambre est
partout et était père était resté au
chai approché j'ai déjà interrogé votre
domestique tout à l'heure en vérité il
me semble que ça n'était pas celui là
j'en ai deux monsieur le baron mais
monsieur utiles sur des voies toujours
porté la libre et certainement il m'a
déjà vu ce matin hambourgeoise tant
mieux
ce doit être un domestique nouveau très
nouveau qui peut vous le faire croire
un vague souvenir que j'ai d'avoir déjà
vu monsieur sous un autre costume
en effet il me sert quelquefois comme
valet de chambre
alors comment expliquez-vous certains
signes que je vois et tu m'étonnes son
trouble du tout j'ai peur je veux dire
j'ai peur d'avoir peur mais son jeu
une certaine noblesse de traîne équipe
havraise moyenne oui je me trahit moi
même je suis si noble en domestique
je vous assure monsieur le baron et nous
vous assurons je suis différent alors si
vous me jurez toutes deux que ce jeune
homme est bien votre choix dans les
pieds non je ne l'interrogent plus je
l'arrêt cette photo soit bien tout va
bien nous sommes bien là mais tu l'as
fait monter là moi non et bien que dites
vous de bonnes idées ont laissé pousser
la raillerie un peu loin et que vous ne
me priverai pas d'un serviteur qui m'a
dit il
j'ai dans la pensée qu'il peut mettre
faire d'utile à moi aussi je le prépare
et pourquoi donc et parce que mais parce
que l'être à l'est mais parce que c'est
un mec à moi et chez moi et que je
réponds la laisse vous êtes perdus
suivent à pied ce papier monsieur je
vous ordonne de me remettre ce papier je
veux défendre ce papier toute résistance
est inutile monsieur le voici monsieur
mêlée perdue
j'aimerais mieux être avec ce que henry
de froeningen mon cher si ce monsieur
henri de flavie niel au long du roi et
de la loi vous arrête ans quel bonheur
opare vous nuit je mens pas monsieur le
baron je vous en supplie ne connais que
boudoir madame la comtesse premier
monsieur dans la pièce voisine
je le conduis assurez-vous de son
identité je m'assure déclaration suffira
ensuite vous connaissez mes instructions
je les connais que voulez-vous dire dieu
mais malheureux garçon
sachez que vous emportez mon estime et
les regrets à permettez monsieur
permettront ne permet pas aux mélodies
de news je la mets donc gaga null null
gaga nous lé new moon
c'est pareil alors supporter a ordonné
madame la comtesse sa monnaie forte
unité
il faut que j'avertis sow plutôt
monsieur le maréchal en rêviez de
mérinville d'un événement de cette
importance
vous trouverez de quoi écrire dans cette
chambre ma nièce va vous le donne et
monsieur diallo c'est vrai il est ici
des 18 en 2010 et malgré son déguisement
je les ai découverts je le tiens
monsieur puisque vous savez tout fleure
silence voici tes 25
qu'est ce que ça signifie je suis au
comble du bonheur car vous êtes sauvés
henry sauvé grâce à ma tempe à dieu
sauve et essorés par sommes en phase
encore j'ai détourner les soupçons du
barreau il croit tenir le coupable mais
temps vous serez dans le château vous
n'aurez pas passer la frontière
je craindrais toujours et moi je ne
crains plus rien place à celle dont
l'esprit dont l'adresse d'esprit de
l'adresse il n'y a que du coeur chéreng
y voit si vous aviez été arrêté j'en
fais mans chaque jour chaque instant me
révélera dont avoue une qualité nouvelle
je cherche en vain dans mon coeur
quelques paroles qui vous disent tous
que j'éprouve en vous qui pouvez vous
qui savez ange paix enchanteresse
enseignements dont le moyen de vous
payer de tout ce que je vous dois vous
ne me devez rien de tout ce que je vous
ai fait souffrir avant de répondre en
vie dites-moi si ces paroles si tendre
sortent bien du fond de votre coeur vous
trajet quel point et bien c'est paris
c'est eh bien mon ami c'est de mai mais
quand je vous ai silence on vient aussi
grâce à vous mademoiselle mon courrier
terminé 6e elle fait ressortir comité
côté c'est bien par donnerez-vous mes
victoires il battra victoire monsieur le
baron ni votre manière de vaincre et
cela le pré que je devais attendre du
service que je vous ai rendu le devoir
pas seulement la reconnaissance tous de
voir comment est-il d'employés la ruse
la trahison mais je le répète la
trahison vous aurait soudoyé quelques
consciences acheter quelqu'un de méchant
osez le nier mais j'y pense oui
ce regard de telli gens avec ce garçon
pause entretien mystérieux que vous
aviez ensemble c'est lui
à misérable serviteur c'est donc vous
qui l'avait trahi i want madame oui où
je vois votre trouble à l'embarras des
barons je vous renvoie je vous chasse
sortait mais il ne restera pas une
minute de plus à mon service
soit et bien je le prends au mien et
pourquoi donc alors mon garçon à cheval
et au galop jusqu'à 5 ans d'école ciel
cette lettre mais pour monsieur le
maréchal en rubis devient mobile
commandes dans la division
mais monsieur le ballon gens pas le
cheval prend le mien même selon les
soldats y verront quoi passer plus donné
les ordres je vous dois ma vie disposé
sans et bien bas à aller dans une âme
seul pas moche mais mon poste là
commentait je suis moi wayne bridge fla
ouais non les plats aa et vous autres
hamel prisonniers indiens
mais c'est trop tôt monsieur le baron de
grâce
vous savez madame je ne suis ni cruel ni
amis des condamnations et si l'on
m'écoute et onu d'accorder cette
amnistie que je demandais je le sais
bien
et bien ce jeune homme mais votre ami ce
jeune homme m'intéresse et je veux
tenter de le sauver de le sauver comment
cela je vais lui parler
si vous attendiez une heure une demi
heure pour le laisser se remettre d'un
premier moment de trouble dans un
instant respect rues sont d'accord et
avant dix minutes tout au plus je saurai
le lui tout ce que j'ai besoin de savoir
si vite c'est à peine s'il sera parti
même encore rouillé vous éloignez je
veux venir
oh mon dieu que faire craignez-vous dont
matt en avant si monsieur grignon faibli
n'at-il pas du courage un courage qui
n'a pas de passion c'est qu'ils ne
durent pas longtemps
[Musique]
laissez-nous seul gars gagnent hall
pauvre jeune homme j'aimerais mieux être
ailleurs approchez approchez
je ne peux pas plus ce monsieur veut
j'ai beaucoup de mal
viva j'aurais dû m'arriver j'ai tenu et
vous voir un instant avant le moment
fatal quel moment fatal essayez vous
vous êtes bien monsieur henri de flavie
gueule qui a ri de farinole avait ex
officier au service de l'empereur et
c'est bien vous qui avez signé cette
déclaration monsieur henri de flaminio
de la vigne on savait mieux
il suffit monsieur sachez que vous aurez
les égards les prérogatives du un bras
et prérogatives
oui si vous voulez quand vous vendent
les yeux si vous voulez vous mêmes
commandé le feu soyez sûrs et coco
commander le feu qu'est ce que cela veut
dire de lui dire monsieur de mise en
ordre sont formels vous avez été jugé
condamné
l'arrêt prononcé je doit l'exécuter tous
les chefs doivent elles être fusillés
sans délai et sans bruit un bruit à à
san siro i am et non pas le genre fait
du moi et moi est ce qu ont fusillé les
gens assis sans jouer et chanter écouter
monsieur s'en vont et dans les têtes
tombent
je dois ajouter la halle objet de notre
entretien qu'il est un moyen de salut
lequel a oui mais peut-être ne voudrez
vous pas l'adopter et pourquoi pas et
pourquoi non monsieur centre 8 2%
il a été décidé oui on accorderait la
vie sauve à tous ceux qui auraient des
déclarations à faire peut-être en avez
vous quelques unes moins mais
certainement une très très importante et
du possible je vous enjoins vous en
réponse une qui est décisive est
catégorique et sexe et que je ne suis
pas là qu'on fasse très bien je suis
d'une inquiétude
assurez vous monsieur de flat vignolles
à qui je viens de parler est prêt à nous
révéler quoi qu'est ce don
qu'avez-vous a révélé - mois
encore quand elle est là je n'ose plus
avoir peur l'instant vous vouliez me
déclarer général ham a déclaré madame
edith lui dit lui voue mendy lui qu'il
super de gaieté de coeur vous avez
raison laissez-moi quelques instants
avec lui je lui expliquerai jet de
l'ascendant sur son esprit soit je vous
laisse en attendant l'arrivée de
monsieur le président de la cour
prévôtale mais pressé madame pressé je
vous laisse avec madame la comtesse
écouter la voix d'une amie jamais ses
yeux se sont portés sur moi avec autant
d amitié oh merci mon ami merci
vous êtes donc contente de moi je ne
demande que quelques instants de fermeté
de courage on met de la fermeté j'en ai
journée j'en ai vous êtes là de ma foi
vous avez bien fait d'arriver vous
impatient entier un peu à même patienter
un peu donc je mourrai tu peux écouter
il faut que faut que mon coeur s'ouvre
devant vous le mensonge me pèse comment
je ne suis pas celui que j'ai voulu pas
être à vos yeux je ne suis pas un héros
au contraire et et quand je dis quand je
dis au contraire ce n'est pas tout à
fait juste car il ya une partie de moi
qui une partie qui enfin je vous
expliquerai cela plus tard quand y'a
t'il que quand monsieur de montrichard
m'a parlé d'être fusillé dans une heure
la peur m'a pris on aurait peur à moi et
je vais la bouche pour mais crier je ne
suis pas monsieur de flavignerot et vous
êtes entré et soudain à votre vue j'ai
senti que je pouvais faire de grandes
choses pourvu que vous fussiez l'a16
rassurez vous je ne trahirai pas
monsieur de flat vignolles mais surtout
ne ne m'abandonnait pas soyez là quand
le préfet reviendra soyez là quand on ne
signifiera la sentence soyez là à
jeumont je suis capable de tout le tout
de tout même de recevoir pour un autre
10 balles au travers du corps pourvu qu
en les recevant je vous entends dire je
suis là
brard garçons car vous êtes brown je
vous connais mieux que vous même
c'est votre imagination qui s'est fait
ce n'est pas un truc bien dans les mois
1,6
il ne vous manque un bon danger qui vous
saisissent à l'improviste
ah oui je crois que j'ai ce qu'il vous
faut j'attends plus longtemps voilà
monsieur le président de la cour et
wotan vient d'arriver il faut que
monsieur de flat vignolles se décide à
parler ou qu'ils me suivent et bien je
vous suivent quoi en revue mon parti et
pris le conseil de guerre la cour
prévôtale dit pas la peine poitrine ça
m'est égal
une fois que j'ai su ça m'est égal mais
pensez vous oui monsieur je suis le fils
de ma mère des cieux
je n'ai jamais douté je l'espère bien à
monsieur partons monsieur calmez vous
j'aurai une ou deux questions
importantes imposées à monsieur le baron
questions importantes oui monsieur le
baron à quelle heure avez vous arrêté
votre prisonniers une heure plus tôt
plus petites mains mais c'est le var on
vous avait dû beaucoup voyagé dans votre
département
sans doute mais alors combien de temps
faut-il pour aller d'ici à mauléon sur
un bon cheval
trois quarts d'heure ou non plus et de
mauléon à la frontière toujours sur un
bon cheval du minutes trois quarts
d'heure et 10 minutes total 55 minutes
il est sauvé attendez donc j'aurai comme
une dernière question à vous adresser
monsieur le président de la cour
prévôtale que vous attendiez
ne vous at il pas été envoyés de paris
et n'est-il pas si je ne me trompe
un ancien sénateur monsieur de grieg en
un même but ici c'est mon oncle mon fils
ils finissent la question monsieur
jeunes pour qu'ils aient plus vous
pouvez conduire au président son neveu
juteux floridienne non monsieur gustave
de grignon que son oncle n'a pas vu
depuis longtemps et c'est à vous
monsieur qu'il devra ce plaisir le
coupable tard il était ici j'en suis sûr
chercher je crois je sais je suis
désabusé soit dans une flat vignes
heures henri de la vigne elle sait quel
autre at-il autre celui à qui vous avez
remis un sauf-conduit celui que vous
avez essayé de séduire celui pour lequel
vous avez imploré ma clément homme je ne
suis pas vaincu et je couvre cette race
inutiles ou nous rattraper jamais vous
croyez bien trop bon cheval soit du
problème lui-même que vous avez pensé à
tout même à l'équipe est témoin c'est
bien celui que je suis sorti pour ordre
car vraiment lui donner des honoraires
pour vous trompez c'est trop fort d'être
un monstre infernal honteux sous froid
tant de duplicité moi moi moi qui écris
au maréchal rubis de berneville je tiens
le chef je me rends voici ce qui arrive
de lyon
nonchalant quel malheur dont il retenu
six ans vit comment il est là je tiens
ma revanche je vais vous dire à votre
rayon fiel et tout à l'heure madame la
comtesse mais à la guerre la fortune est
changeante
grâce à ce document comment voir
monsieur le maréchal rudy delaere ma
ville je puis forcé le fugitif en
quelques lieux qu'ils se trouvent à se
remettre mon pouvoir
ou comment c'est mon secret mais à fond
je tiens à vous prouver que je puis me
venger fois jamais les poussins de
montrichard monsieur de grillons je vais
prévenir monsieur votre ongle qu'ils
viennent vous rendre à la liberté il
pouvait disposer à météo
ajouter les espoirs compte c'est nos
billes
adieu la comtesse sicile d'autres
vallées de kermadio
comme a dit henri vinay la voici lui
alors que voulez vous faire ici une fois
avez vous pu croire je serai périr un
innocent à ma place ferrer le vieux
gardien compris ma fille m'a tout appris
monsieur crayon c'est pas faire pour moi
monsieur de grilles ont été arrêtés pour
moi et monsieur de grignon et libre est
malheureuse enfant anthony et qu'il vous
le dise lui même non monsieur un tel
dévouement
ce n'est qu'un devoir a toujours dit
qu'elle allait encore une fois pour
toutes a été dissipé conjurer toute
encore comment le dernier lieu où l'on
vous cherchera maintenant c'est ici
monsieur mon histoire d'un parti vous en
sentinelle sur le balcon pour guetter
son départ chico je risque et en
refroidissement oblige tout le cabinet
mais je le veux et dans quelques
instants plus de danger peut partager
maintenant mais sécurité ma joie tu
pleures non je ne pleure pas m'attend je
ne pleure plus je suis heureuse il est
sauvé mais en même temps chez sur
désespoir car tout à l'heure quand il
est revenu ici à prudemment
quand je les cacher dans ce cabinet où
je tremblais pour lui il m'a dit que non
puisque je sais ce que je fais me
rappeler tout ce que j'ai compris c'est
tout était fini pour moi j'entends que
nous ne pouvions jamais être l'un à
l'autre c'est juste il fallait bien le
lui dire pour enfants et tu lui en veux
tu le détestes au nom ma tante mais jean
bourrel à l'aller on y allons voyons il
faut de la raison si par exemple il
était liée à une autre personne
justement c'est ce qu'il m'a dit yahya
jammeh est un homme est cette personne
non il ne l'a pas voulu mais vous ma
tante est ce que vous la connaissez
je crois que oui en vérité et savez-vous
si elle aime beaucoup
oh oui et elle est aimable et les jolis
traits aura moins que toi
et bien alors qu'avec une machine on ne
discute pas avec son coeur et quelle
qu'elle soit si il la préfère cieux
l'été mais pas du tout c'est moi qu'ils
n
c'est moi il me l'avouer juliel par le
respect par l'amitié que sais-je par la
reconnaissance le reconnaissent oui il
est surtout par une promesse qui lui a
fait et qu'il tiendra même au prix de
son sang
voilà qui est absurde dites le lui ma
tante vous seul pouvez le décide et déjà
rentré de grâce monsieur richard arrivé
à ma porte
j'aime mieux mourir que de vampires à
votre promesse c'est bien oui mais bator
six mois lui paraît je vous dois ma vie
disposés en avez vous dire quels sujets
vous la seule chose que j'ai désiré
rêver poursuivi votre bonheur chez
vernis ory voici celles qu'il faut
choisir ciel or mon ami mon ami j'étais
bien sûr que ces fouilles devraient
voici monsieur machin
moi s'ils savaient fort bien vous faire
des adieux et madame la comtesse
avant de partir je tiens à vous prouver
que je ne me sentais pas cette dépêche
l ordonnance que je sollicitais depuis
si longtemps l'ordonnancé amnistie l'as
nancy
ils pensent que je ne ferais pas être
inquiet sur le flanc droit et la loi
je vous déclare ne voyez-vous pas que
monsieur le baron de prendre sa revanche
jeudi nous joue là une scène de terreur
à monza on ne peut pas plus la trompait
ont bien connu les femmes à qui le
dites-vous je suis mal il a gagné
oui mais plus tard qu'aujourd'hui je
dois partir partie vous pensez alors
alors je parle ce pas aussi
ah oui vous avez vous dire non je peux
rien ne m'arrête je me suis juste
jusqu'au bout du monde jusqu'au bout du
monde et je me faisant j'accomplirai
devant vous de si belles choses que vous
finirez par vous dire voilà voilà pauvre
garçon dont j'ai fait un héros
faisons-en un homme heureux
cécile gustave
et via les barons j'ai perdu comtesse je
suis venu vous n'êtes pas le seul
que voulez-vous baron pour bien jouer
pour gagner
il ne suffit pas de bien jouer il faut
avoir les as et les rois le roi surtout
dans les batailles de da que la fête
foraine et que nos gens se réjouit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cieux
la pièce ma taille deux dames un duel en
amour que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer devant de ce soir et de messieurs
eugène scribe et ernest legouvé tous
deux de l'académie phone 7
un seul victor hugo china
des costumes de donald cardwell
mise en scène de robert manuel
ap
listing peinture et michel adam
à la salle marianne ou deux
georges montillet et agnès chatrier
jean-pierre shameless une jacqueline
joly fait
daniel bouteille et milian de colombie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
oh
hélas
[Musique]